Oh beautiful I look at that countryside
it's so it's so lush we can look down
[Laughter]
look at that
fresh country air Joey he hello you have
returned I have returned and so has
potato mode we very special episode it's
bringing at least a year I think since
the last episode that we did and of
course the only reason why we would ever
want to bring it back again would be for
the biggest graphical monster of all
time I would say Red Dead Redemption -
this is probably still one of the most
beautiful games out there and it's got a
PC release finally which means of course
we have to make it look like absolute
mud but we do I'm just I'm looking at
now I haven't seen any footage of it yet
and this looks amazing
like actually amazing it's also not even
running at max settings this is really
mid to high on this computer I have seen
it run on max max settings and oh boy it
is a visual treats but we're not here to
look at how good it is yeah actually
before before we start like I guess we
can kind of recap what we even do on the
show in case people haven't already seen
it before but basically what we do is we
take these games that look absolutely
gorgeous like ready redemption - and we
just try to make a look as Kerdi as
possible either by turning the settings
all the way down in the game itself to
see how far it goes and then we'll try
to take it even further than that using
some some other other matters lit oh
yeah this is the first fight I'll pick
up you hat
hold on here I gotta find my hat well
being in the Chaco I got this What did
he say
what business is there yours I forgot
how much I love Arthur I know I think my
favorite is the way he says what about
the moaning which is every other scene
yeah all right Joey I think we've shown
off a little bit of the game how good it
looks how good this mud yeah it looks
really good so I think like to recap I
think the main things that have really
really changed is draw distance mm-hmm
frame rate obviously and I think I would
say the lighting it feels a lot crisper
oh that's all gonna go out the window
very soon yeah I mean let's just throw
caution to the wind just go down one by
one everything to the end everything's
everything's going down water physics I
don't want completely of no water
physics motion blur tree quality low
quality can't put lower than medium Wow
kind of weird okay whoa we haven't even
done anything fancy yet okay I assume
that was just loading in yeah really
wish that was like that the entire time
oh me too okay so um the textures on the
ground textures missing some definite
some it looks like you got it just wax
completely yeah but it's still really
you can still play this yeah and have it
be passable the draw distance hasn't
been changed at all for some reason yeah
I mean those trees are a little rough
out out there but with the water you
know a little shimmer on that water
there that's nice I mean well one thing
we didn't do we didn't change the
resolution we go resolution scale mm-hmm
and I can have it okay this is the
lowest one to go which is which is
honestly not that low like really but
half of that
oh that's true we are getting half of
that oh there we go nice and legal like
a nice ps2 game
well maybe ps3 a ps3 game with just
really like to get it to run well they
had a really really lower the resolution
okay so I think we've pushed the game in
its current form as much as we can so
now we're gonna get into the games guts
and really just gonna blow it up from
the inside
wriggle around in there so let's uh
let's why do we do like that analogy
let's do it ah this is a girlfriend here
so we're gonna start with with Joey's
good old friends the nvidia profile
inspector 0 x 0 0 0 0 0 f 0 i think it's
5 and then so okay yeah yeah that works
ok that's that's it I just can't believe
I remembered that one on that one and
there was one more I want to show
someone next to it as well you could do
both I think it depends on what the game
runs on Wow well I guess we'll find out
it's possible and then hit texture
filtering a little bit below 2nd to the
bone yeah right there that should be
performance I think ok high performance
so we wanted to we want quality here
mm-hmm
and I think that was it and you just add
apply changes yeah apply changes ok
let's let's take a look yes we'll see if
it does anything find out mmm nothing I
think yeah we are back to just I think
we might need it there might be some
settings we missed but I I want to say
read dead might be immune to the charms
of the Nvidia profile inspector that's
sad oh man I know but it's ok because we
have a backup alright Joey we're
bringing it back very old-school to the
first episode of potato mode oh my god I
remember this Rob did grand theft auto 5
here we come Oh
oh those are all the cars in the city I
think that is also rockstar games the
settings are very similar which means I
can get right into here into the load
bias and we're gonna we're gonna mess
with a couple of things here so when you
when you go down to the log bias or load
bias it typically needs to be positive
in order for it to make a difference
yeah
so if you do if I do 0.2 okay and then
pedestrian load bias maybe make that 3
3.0 so why did they what I watch the GTA
1 you had them at negative negative
okay maybe do negative that's free let's
just miss some stuff up that's all I can
say oh definitely for sure
look at the chicken yes okay so how was
the draw distance that's the real
question
not as bad in my my initial test
settings
it was worse so there's still a more we
can do later so I think we got the
pedestrian yeah we're doing bias he is
suffering from the same thing that
Michael was in GTA 5 where his clothing
is all the sudden like the texture of
the clothing we turn him around let me
see his front but mmm that's not his
skin get him out of Gitmo the the
shadows my favorite part is a dutch over
there it's just a wait
do you have binoculars oh yes we're
gonna be using that a lot I think first
of all his cigars backwards
oh that's Bernie on the other side and
secondly how do we even know this is
Dutch we can't see the red the red scarf
or something it's true you don't know
you get closer you shan't agonism
we I don't know if you can do that yes I
think you need a hat I'm supposed to be
wearing one um but I was saying about
the horse
[Laughter]
all right let's let's go to I think
uncle I think he has the next mission
that we want I'm not sure what's worse
the the horse is here or that what are
you where I'm walking on something
that's invisible the horse is here or
the the cars in gta5 I don't know what's
worse but I'm an uncle you looking nice
and smooth ever seen that game ever
played like in the movies the movies I
remember the name I don't know what it
was it's like an old I was like a like a
sim game where you like run a movie
studio yes I remember that all of them
all of the figures when you're like
creating your scenes look like those uh
like mannequins you get at like an art
school that was that was wait a minute
second hold on I wouldn't say that
that's pre-written holy crap okay are
they because they're pre-rendered you'll
know you look like [ __ ] you lost a lot
of features fishable we gotta we gotta
use you guys going to town get you some
new clothes
Arthur we got to get you any clothes I
really hope they stay that way oh no
never mind
they're back - this is like like I was
gonna say they're the characters the
horses everything here kinda looks like
these little like like children's block
Toye yes many of them like the kind you
get would that come like a log cabin yes
I love the horses they're so they're so
simple looking it makes this it's much
more charming than it used to be
yeah they look really cute they look
like with chocolate bars it's like some
textures are fine and the others are
just completely destroyed you can you
can read the hotel you can read the
general stores good okay so I was saying
earlier about the the clothing on these
characters and Arthur he he's basically
doing the same thing that Michael was in
the GTA 5 episode where the shirt is
like I want to say it's turned the
textures like turn diagonally or
sideways and it's just flat against his
entire body because that's why his like
head is also blue the color of his shirt
this is blending into it was 1890 this
guy's Olivia in 2099 parallel apparently
the doors open oh hello welcome to the
super detailed general store I browse
the catalog if we can read it oh oh no
the game crashed that's something I
never would have thought would happen
all right well that's a good opportunity
to maybe get back into the game
getting's I think that's a ludus skip I
think do that negative three yeah we'll
keep that where are we where it can't
you sure okay we maybe went too hard
I mean we we might I can't I'm bumping
into someone let me drive for a little
bit yeah sure here if you could uh uncle
who's right there ish yep yep hold the
whole left rigger wake him up do you
think the girls will still be fine
that's what I'm that's what I'm curious
about
okay oh okay let me skip this but
they're normally so what happens when
they go back I can totally get to town I
love you can see the grass gettin kicked
up in the wheels see we just just drive
automatically that's the the sub UT of
Red Dead cinematic camera you just lay
and then maybe we should maybe we should
uh we should dial it back and you think
a touch I think maybe I'm not sure what
what setting is to do then
so we've we need we need to peel it back
just a tad to get to where where we need
to be so which one do we do we even do I
think it's it's uh the load scale and
you want like negative one one okay
let's try that there we go lightly
better you can see the knife now so at
least we know where we're going
that's the most important thing x-rays
uh some things are loading could sure
try go go look around the camp let's see
if we can interact oh okay some things
are loading in oh you see those trails
okay oh boy I'd recognize those pistols
anywhere you see a shadow oh yeah
who's that look at that knife I wanna
say that's that's maybe oh you can see
the cigar oh my god wait wait how do I
uh-huh right there and then yep there
you go oh oh this is how we see into the
the alternate dimension yeah here yeah
it's not much better so this is what we
got in order to find where we need to go
we need to look through here first and
then be like okay I need to go that
direction Joey I think we just invented
a new video game to panic
isn't that no that has to be something
right yeah were you like use the
binoculars to see like in - no that's
that's something like recently right oh
is it I don't know I want to say it's
like oh there was a game like called
perception I know that was like you're
blind but yet to use like echolocation
yeah but not something like this where
you have to like peer into the alternate
universe to see what's in your current
one the grass isn't loading anymore
which is weird because we didn't change
it no don't worry about a thing
it does wait why is there another horse
here
wait is that I don't know I don't ask
what maybe I lost a horse somewhere I
don't know if higher or lower is better
I think lower I need low lower when zero
five zero five point zero
eight 7.07 let's try that
whoo yes okay this I think this is this
is a good balance here's what I was
looking for enough that we can see but
but pretty pretty bad it feels like
everything's just floating now a little
bit so uh touch you sure every transom
did the binoculars still do the let you
see
oh no the lighting still looks really
good
that's some great God raise you can see
Valentine from here oh you can Wow
exactly we're rolling the whole map is
like phasing in oh there's a good
there's a good a cliff AB hold on hold
on do it a little alright girls getting
into town oh no it's not letting me oh
there's like rocks in the way in the way
[Music]
yep mm-hmm
still alive okay although it's funnier
when they're not detailed the level of
detail it was constantly shifting yeah
it's like trying to unload certain
things but also like keep the detail in
the background and it uh it's just kind
of going haywire oh we got so many trees
to navigate through invisible trees
they're like phasing in and out of
existence
back up can you shoot them yeah maybe
here hold on come on let me let me end
it will heat your Oh what no okay that's
right here we go nice and simple simple
polygons simple textures simple oh it's
just like mud Oh No okay so we need to
go back to the general store again oh
great crap I think don't go into the
like actually try and physically just
buy it yeah don't go into the the
catalog just buy it off the off the rack
now here we go here we go
shows me on than that
all right let's get out of here
nope no video game alright that was the
sound of my head hitting the desk losing
along moseying on into town like the
horse animation it's the same really the
same but it looks worse because you can
basically see the skeleton that they
were working with yeah this this is what
I'm talking about how do we how do we
commit these low-quality crimes exactly
he's like the opposite of dirty arty
[Laughter]
look at this skidmark you made what did
I hit I don't know you know it clearly
wasn't a person we sound think so I'll
go this way
oh hello I think these are some some
other gang members yeah
Theo Driscoll's
Oh invisible oh and now he's he's fine
come on back your horse of course Chris
[Laughter]
I'm sorry that didn't know hate it
I didn't load in for me you can keep the
body leave him there so witness what did
he win this though I wouldn't know how
to discuss oh no an some blocky ass man
just came in jumped the fence and left
the body starting to streak a little bit
like does that randomly we mention photo
mode so just like the photo mode run on
different like rules than the game I
don't know exactly what rule it's
breaking right now but is this hat
floating it's the magic of the old
Driscoll hats cuz remember you did you
didn't take off yours exactly they just
have really really tiny heads so I need
any hat they put on maybe oh I'm really
bummed it kept crashing and we lost his
facial hair change cuz we don't you know
what oh you won't get you want to get a
barber yeah yeah let's get a barber cut
blind it and then lose why are you
holding it like that sir that's all I
hold a broom
I don't why would that why would it do
that
hello sir is the mirror still work
barely kind of whoa you can see outside
oh that's freaky that doesn't one the
mirror wouldn't
him but also everything okay let's get a
haircut
it's yeah you oh you got to talk to the
barber right no no it says law it might
be too early no it's not too early is it
like in the day like maybe he's not open
yet I love about everyone just in
addition to them being like low-poly
like the angle of what everything that
they're holding is just completely wrong
don't get it
Oh can you get oh go to the inn take a
bath Owen here looks really nice I know
I love how some things are just no red
deck oh okay
it's such a bummer such a bummer but at
the same time like I feel satisfied I
feel satisfied too but there there are
so many things I want to test I want to
try for myself you in the watching this
video please send me and Joey like on
Twitter examples of what I want to know
like try this for yourself and if you
can get the bath working you can get
like the Lenny the Lenny mission I need
to see it for myself please please let
me see this I need to know alright
everyone thank you for watching this
episode of potato mode I would probably
I don't think we're bringing it back as
a regular series but maybe we'll
occasionally come back for for some
special occasion with whatever the heavy
hitters are in the PC gaming world yeah
the test strandings apparently coming
out PC next year so maybe we'll come
back for that one anyway this has been
potato mow Joey thanks for coming back
thanks for having me and see y'all next
time stay stay potato is that is that
what you said I don't know if I did if
you have a catch a cat let's let's leave
that that state potato
stay fresh keep it potatoes everyone see
you guys